THEN HE CONTINUES TO CONDEMN
VIOLENCE IN ALL FORMS.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTED TO THE
NEWS AT HIS RALLY IN WISCONSIN
LAST NIGHT.
>> President Trump: MY HIGHEST
DUTY, AS YOU KNOW AS PRESIDENT
IS TO KEEP AMERICA SAFE.
ANY ACT OR THREAT OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE ARE AN ATTACK ON OUR
DEMOCRACY ITSELF.
WE WANT ALL SIDES TO COME
TOGETHER IN PEACE AND HARMONY.
THE MEDIA ALSO HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO SET A CIVIL
TONE AND STOP THE ENDLESS
HOSTILITY AND CONSTANT NEGATIVE
AND OFTENTIMES FALSE ATTACKS.
>> Dana: PAM, CAN WE START
WITH YOU?
TRACE GALLAGHER'S THING THAT WE
CONFIRM THEY ARE HONING IN ON
FLORIDA AS A POSSIBLE PLACE
WHERE THESE PACKAGES WERE SENT
FROM.
>> Pam: WITHOUT DETAILS
SPECIFICALLY TO FLORIDA COME AS
A CAREER PROSECUTOR, I'VE SEEN
SO MANY OF THESE CASES WITH
SUSPICIOUS PACKAGES.
THERE IS A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION, DANA, AND THE
PACKAGES.
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
EVEN THE DUCT TAPE.
I HAD A MURDER CASE.
STAMPS THAT YOU USED TO LICK.
NOW WE HAVE TOUCHED DNA.
IF THEY TOUCH THE STAMP, WE CAN
GET DNA OFF THE STAMP.
AS TO THE POST OFFICE, WE CAN
EVEN GET THE ORIGIN AS TO WHERE
IT CAME.
I THINK THEY ARE WORKING ON ALL
THAT.
WAS IT WELL-PLANNED?
YES AND NO.
THEY ALL WENT OUT
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
HOWEVER NO, IN THAT NAMES WERE
SPELLED WRONG.
SOME OF THE ADDRESS AS WE KNOW
ARE WRONG AND GOT RETURNED TO
SENDER.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK THAT
COULD'VE BEEN ON PURPOSE?
>> Pam: MAY BE.
I KNOW THAT THEY KNOW A LOT MORE
THAN WE KNOW AND THAT'S HOW IT
SHOULD BE RIGHT NOW AND I REALLY
HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THEY WILL
CATCH THIS PERSON VERY FAST.
I SAW THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY
THE WHITE HOUSE, AND HE WAS SO
SOMBER.
YOU SAW HIM.
HE WAS SO SOMBER.
VERY SERIOUSLY, EVERYONE IS
TAKING THIS.
THE FBI'S ALL OVER IT.
>> Dana: GREG, LET'S GO TO YOU
YOU.
ONGOING CONVERSATION.
YOU SEE THE ACTIVITY THIS
MORNING?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TIME IT WAS.
I AM A FEW BLOCKS FROM THERE, SO
I WOKE UP TO THE HELICOPTERS
THAT WERE I GUESS ABOVE ME FOR
AT LEAST A FEW HOURS.
I GOT UP AND TOLD MY WIFE, I GO,
"SOMETHING'S HAPPENING.
IT'S DEFINITELY DOWNTOWN."
AND THEN IT WENT ON FOR A COUPLE
HOURS.
>> Dana: WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THE CONVERSATION TODAY THAT WAS
INEVITABLE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS TONE, IS
SAYING THAT THE MEDIA NEEDS TO
WATCH THE STONE.
>> Greg: ALL THESE THINGS
COMING OR GOING TO GET
FINGER-POINTING.
EVERYONE CAN POINT FINGERS,
DEPENDING ON WHAT GROUP YOU
BELONG TO.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO TAKE ADVICE
FROM THE MEDIA OVERHEATED
RHETORIC, BECAUSE IF YOU WERE TO
SUBTRACT THE HEATED RHETORIC OF
TRUMP.
LET'S SAY THE CAUSTIC BEHAVIOR,
THE JOKES ABOUT SLEEPY EYES AND
LOCK HIM UP.
IF YOU TOOK IT ALL AWAY, YOU
WOULD STILL HAVE SPEAKERS ON
CAMPUS BEING HARASSED.
HE WOULD STILL HAVE ANTIFA
CHASING DOWN PEOPLE ON STREETS.
HE WOULD STILL HAVE POLITICIANS
INCITING FACE-TO-FACE
HARASSMENT.
KATHY GRIFFIN, JOHNNY DEPP,
MADONNA.
THEY ALL DID THAT STUFF EARLY
ON.
YOU HAVE MIKA ASSESSING OVER THE
25TH AMENDMENT.
EVENT TWO YEARS OF QUESTIONING
TRUMP'S SANITY, CALLING HIM
HITLER.
AND YOU ARE UPSET ABOUT HE MADE
A JOKE ABOUT A BODY SLAM.
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
>> Dana: I THINK THE LEFT
WOULD FEEL DIFFERENTLY.
>> Juan: I THINK THE LEFT
FEELS LIKE IT'S A DIFFICULT
MOMENT FOR ALL OF US.
IT'S A VERY DIVIDED COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW, AND I THINK IT'S KIND
OF SAD THAT WE'VE REACHED THIS
POINT.
I THINK PEOPLE ON THE LEFT ARE
KIND OF TAKEN ABACK.
THE PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT SEEMED
TO BE MORE PRESIDENTIAL AND
SAYING THAT WE NEED TO UNIFY,
COME TOGETHER.
YOU CAN'T ATTACK POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THIS MORNING HE SHIFTS AGAIN, AS
YOU ARE SUGGESTING TO GREG, AND
SAYS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA NEEDS
TO CLEAN UP ITS ACT IN TERMS OF
SETTING THE TONE.
THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN PRETTY
CLEAR.
JEFF ZUCKER, THE HEAD OF CNN,
AND OTHERS SAYING THAT THE TONE
IS REALLY SET BY THE POLITICIAN,
THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO IS
TALKED ABOUT SECOND AMENDMENT
PEOPLE TAKING CARE OF HILLARY
AND BODY SLAMMING REPORTERS.
I CAN GO ON.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS.
EVEN IN CHARLOTTESVILLE, WITH
FINE PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
I THINK THERE'S A SENSE THAT HIS
INSTINCT IS TO BE A COMBATIVE
PRESIDENT AND THAT IN FACT AS A
POLITICAL STRATEGY APPROACHING
THE MIDTERMS, HE SEES THE
DIVISION AS FIRING UP HIS BASE
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST
WORRY THAT YOU CAN'T -- WE CAN'T
AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KEEP
GOING DOWN THIS PATH WITHOUT
RESPECTING, DARE SAY LOVING EACH
OTHER, AS FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> Dana: LAST WEEK AND THE NBC
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" POLL, 90%
OF AMERICANS SAID WE ARE THE
MOST DIVIDED WE'VE EVER BEEN.
WE ACTUALLY AGREE ON SOMETHING.
THE CONVERSATION WE COULD HAVE
ABOUT RHETORIC COULD HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT THESE
SUSPICIOUS PACKAGES.
IT'S BASIC THAT'S TRUE.
IT'S BEEN BOILING UP FOR A LONG
TIME.
TALKING ABOUT TONE, JUAN BROUGHT
UP, WE MAKE FUN OF CROOKED
HILLARY AND WE SAY POCAHONTAS
AND MAKE FUN OF SPARTACUS.
>> Greg: AND THAT IS JUST YOU.
>> Jesse: WE GO AFTER PEOPLE'S
POLICIES AND WE MOCK THEM IF
THEY ARE BEING DECEITFUL AND
WHAT HAVE YOU.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY THIS TABLE
SAYS THIS PERSON IS A NAZI.
THIS PERSON HATES OTHER ETHNIC
GROUPS.
I WANT TO SEE THIS POLITICAL
OPPONENT, I WANT TO SEE HARM
DONE TO THAT PERSON.
I THINK WE ARE PRETTY
RESPONSIBLE AT THIS TABLE.
WHEN STEVE SCALISE WAS SHOT, NO
ONE AT THIS TABLE BLAMED
BERNIE SANDERS.
BERNIE SANDERS HIMSELF NEVER
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY.
PELOSI NEVER ACCEPTED
RESPONSIBILITY WHEN PEOPLE RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT DEMOCRATIC
RHETORIC.
GREG LAID IT OUT.
THE LIST IS LONG.
PEOPLE'S RIBS HAVE BEEN CRACKED,
PEOPLE UP AND TRIED TO BE
STABBED, CARS HAVE BEEN
FIREBOMBED.
ANTHRAX AND RICIN HAVE BEEN SENT
AROUND.
KATHY GRIFFIN, SNOOP DOGG,
HILLARY CLINTON THE OTHER DAY
SAYING THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO BE
CIVIL.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO BE UNCIVIL.
WE NEVER MAKE DEMOCRATS
ACCESSORY TO THE CRIMES
POLITICALLY.
WHAT THE LEFT IS DOING NOW AS
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE
DONALD TRUMP AN ACCESSORY TO
THESE ATTEMPTED MAIL BOMBINGS
AND SAYING THAT YOU ARE AN
ACCESSORY AND THEREFORE YOU NEED
TO STOP ATTACKING THE MEDIA AND
YOU NEED TO STOP ATTACKING
DEMOCRATS BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT.
I AGREE, TRUMP TALKS TOUGH
SOMETIMES.
SOMETIMES IT'S TOO TOUGH.
A LOT OF TIMES HE'S BEING
TONGUE-IN-CHEEK AND THE MEDIA
HAS NO SENSE OF HUMOR AND THEY
DON'T GET IT.
I AGREE SOMETIMES HE DOES CROSS
THE LINE.
WHEN YOU ARE SLAMMING SOMEONE IN
THE VIDEO YOU'RE GOING LIKE THIS
AND YOU'RE MOCKING SOMEONE
GETTING PUNCHED, IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN WHEN THE MEDIA
CALLS YOU A MENTALLY ILL NAZI